We have some stunning new polling numbers
which should serve to do nothing.
And other than to reinforce the opportunity
that we have to remove Donald Trump in November
if we all get out and vote.
This is a stunning new poll out of North Carolina,
which puts Joe Biden seven points ahead of
Donald Trump.
This is not a Democratic leaning poll.
In fact, it gives Biden a bigger advantage
over Trump than two recent left leaning polls
from Change Research and Peepee, which respectively
have Biden plus one and plus four.
This poll of registered voters says Biden
is winning by seven.
And as we approach Election Day, I've said
before we will see a transition from registered
voter models being used in polling to likely
voter models.
And what's interesting is that the admittedly
Democratic leaning Change Research poll is
a likely voter model and may actually be more
accurate in Joe Biden's lead in North Carolina.
If indeed it exists maybe significantly smaller
than the seven points that we have most recently
seen.
On average, Joe Biden's lead in North Carolina
is now three.
Now, as a reminder, in 2016, Donald Trump
won North Carolina by a little more than three
and a half points.
And certainly losing North Carolina would
be a really bad signal for Donald Trump and
one that, you know, depending on the numbers
we might know about relatively early on November
3rd.
North Carolina being on the East Coast, voting
closes earlier than a lot of other states.
And if it's not even close in North Carolina,
we might know that very early in the evening.
And that would be an important signal about
the way the election is going to go.
Now, just as important out of North Carolina,
based on what we were talking about yesterday,
the Democratic Senate candidate, Cal Cunningham,
has a nine point lead in the same poll over
the incumbent Republican Senator Thom Tillis.
This would be a huge victory.
This would be tremendous in the context of
Democrats maybe taking the Senate, as we were
discussing yesterday.
So now it's time for a word of caution that
is different than my warning from earlier
about everybody has to vote and Trump can
win.
That was a general sort of word of caution.
Now, I want to be a little more specific.
We see Joe Biden winning on average by almost
eight points in Florida, six in Wisconsin,
eight in Michigan, seven in Pennsylvania,
four in Arizona.
This should remind us that we can't underestimate
Donald Trump.
Remember that in 2018, a record number of
Republicans voted in the midterms.
And because Democrats also had record turnout,
we picked up a bunch of seats in the House.
So if Democrats in 2020 and left leaning independents
merely match prior turnout, we could easily
lose.
So as we see these numbers, as important as
they are, as signals about an opportunity
to not only defeat Donald Trump and maybe
take the Senate and grow the majority in the
House, we should be reminded that when Republicans
see this polling, they may become more vote
motivated to vote.
Some may write these polls office fake polls,
but not all of them, meaning we need to not
just match but exceed our biggest ever turnout.
And I believe we need to dramatically exceed
it as we approach November.
If the administration is indeed lying about
rhinovirus numbers, if you see successful
efforts to restrict absentee voting by mail,
close polling places, federal paramilitary
troops intimidating voters like if you add
all of this stuff up a little bit.
A little bit.
Death of a thousand cuts.
We need not just to exceed prior turnout,
but we need to dramatically exceed prior turnout
in order to not allow this to be a missed
opportunity.
Maybe Trump won't get out the vote.
Great.
We benefit, OK?
Maybe Trump won't be able to suppress the
vote because judges are a quote.
You.
Who knows.
Will prevent fantastic.
Whatever.
We can't control that.
And so what we can do is vote ourselves and
get out the vote and make sure that we are
so overwhelming turnout that the dirty tricks
can't work.
There will be dirty tricks.
We're already seeing them.
There's no question that there will be dirty
tricks.
The question is, will they matter?
Because if we really boost turnout in a way
that typically nobody does.
Everybody talks about boosting turnout and
rarely does it.
Does it really happen to the.
Three that I'm thinking about and many people
are thinking about, only if we do that can
we say the dirty tricks won't work.
The dirty tricks won't be enough.
And that's exactly what we need to hope for.
Now, in the meantime, Donald Trump.
I don't know if this is a good strategy.
I'll talk about it.
Donald Trump is just insisting the polls are
fake.
And that may actually be a counterproductive
strategy for him.
I'm going
to
talk
about
that next.